and he's uh swinging as well hold up
guys
i just gotta just one second just one
second i really wanted to do this for
you guys so that you know
what happened last time doesn't occur
you you good with some tape you want
some
of the pants for the pants and that's
that's for your lips man so
bryce had come up with props already
nice belt buckle
did i miss one what did i miss a buckle
no it looked nice
it's good it looks good could be a
little bigger maybe
oh wow well it's good
they're probably hurting inside right
now
oh i wasn't expecting that let me just
say that
all right so good that is gonna be all
right perfect let's
get you some of that there bryson what
is nine flies twenty
five last night i don't know let's see
oh okay yeah
i mean on national tv with a 51 year old
out driving you could it can't happen
like i can't have that it's not okay not
here for 30 minutes you know they're
over there greasing the the refs
like they're trying to put us on ice
they had they had 15 seconds to find it
for the last minute and a half
and down it goes
why would you just give me that and just
save a little time on the back end
oh he's walking oh he's walking inside
nice thank you
get left just a little take it win
all right that's people and i won the
long drive challenge
dude that was passing
the thing was killed though it was
killed no question
had some heat on it i mean it's in the
trees
and i won the long drive challenge again
yep that the leader of the packers i
think
uh you know so i'm gonna be i'm just
watching his mannerisms i'm studying i'm
her recruiting a little bit
just hey you're starting the wrong guy
man aaron looks more lazy now than i did
in retirement
oh whoa i don't know if aaron's hearing
all this but feel free to check in there
aaron
talking about my quarterback what do you
say girl exactly oh aaron's on the line
i didn't even know that oh yeah they're
all listening
they're all listening go ahead go ahead
caller let's rob
from the beach go ahead rob hey aaron
how you doing
hey buddy looking a little slow out
there right now
oh it's a little wet
you talking about my phone no
diddy walk it in aaron thank you
partner my man
[Music]
bryce you got any bear spray on you pal
spray on me
do you have any on you we'll we'll let
you know
okay thank you i can just fight it
myself bro
fight fight a bear yeah yeah fighting a
bear
stalk them in the face i don't think
that'd go over well